okay so the batman gives us a showdown
for the ages in which the dark knight
faces off against the riddler in the
streets of gotham batman eventually
learns the whereabouts of the character
towards the end of the film after he
snipes falcone from his apartment window
however he could have actually caught
him sooner had he paid attention to the
photos of the mayor these were clearly
taken from a high vantage point
overlooking the iceberg lounge which we
later find out is edward nashton's home
we even get a wide shot of the club at
one point and in the top corner we can
see nashton looking out of his window
taking photos of the lounge had batman
figured whereabouts the photos were
taken he could have caught nash in
sooner and the movie would have been
about 10 minutes long which yet not as
fun as what we got so sorry for ruining
your day now this is very much a year 2
story in which bruce is completely
inexperienced so we can excuse this like
my parents he makes major mistakes and
throughout the movie he refuses to
accept the bruce wayne side of his
personality although i've seen people
complaining about this i actually think
it's the whole point of the film and had
he embraced this earlier then he would
have learned about the renewal project
sooner early on alfred tells bruce that
the accountants from wayne manor want to
meet with him as wayne enterprises as
getting into serious trouble this is
likely because it's hemorrhaging cash in
order to line the pockets of falcone and
the corrupt people of gotham had bruce
met with them he could have learned the
truth early on and then he wouldn't have
had to discover it through edward
nashton who also just happens to be an
accountant now i absolutely love this
detail and it somewhat shows bruce's
downfall is the fact that he's so
stubborn i think going forward that this
is very much the reason that he'll need
to do a bruce wayne begins and very much
bring that side of his personality into
the light this idea is showcased in the
film itself as when he first sees
sunlight he squints because of how
bright it is however at the end of the
movie he looks up at the sun without
shifting his gaze because he's finally
ready to become a beacon of hope i don't
think it'll be long before bruce wayne
introduces himself to the world and
speaking of introductions i've just
realized i haven't told you who i am the
hell are you supposed to be i am wade
what no no this is the heavy spoiler
show i'm your host paul aka [ __ ]
grayson the guy who's here to put a
harvey dent on youtube with all my
atrocious puns but sometimes i get some
little nice details i can tell you
that'll hopefully help you enjoy the
film more i don't think these easter
eggs have been brought up in any of the
breakdowns and if you enjoy it we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up by
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the rest of the breakdown
okay so the movie opens with the riddler
spying on the mez sun before he moves
into the home to murder the main man
this young boy is dressed in a red ninja
costume and throughout the film bruce
encounters him at several points now i'd
love to see this kid become robin at
some point and much in the same way that
bruce had a traumatic childhood this kid
does too the mayor's death scene is a
big one and we actually see some major
parallels here between the riddler and
batman much like batman steps out of the
shadows the riddlers too and the
characters even carry some similarities
in their masks placing them side by side
we can see that the nose pieces are very
similar and they of course are both
geniuses that want to take down the
corrupting gotham now batman overseeing
gotham is also metaphorically shown in
the riddle's apartment which we visit
later on in the movie here he has a bat
in a cage and just below it there are
several rats which very much represents
batman and gotham he is the bat hanging
above it as his sole protector whilst
the corrupt rats scurry below now the
film culminates with the seawall being
destroyed which floods gotham however
this is actually foreshadowed early on
at the mayor's home during the debate
with bella real he says she wants to gut
the renewal project which will mean that
several of the sea world funds are
heavily depleted beyond this though we
can also catch a newspaper wall
chronicling don's winds and if you zoom
in on the one below the ellen lies you
can catch a mention of this it asks
whether the seawall construction has
been stalled and due to the corruption
in gotham we now know that this is a
weak point that the riddler later
exploits from here we go to the streets
and get bruce's narration the shot of
him pacing through the streets is akin
to batman year one in which he strolled
downtown on his first mission amongst
these flashes we get a criminal robbing
the good times grocery store now there
have been several videos that pointed
out that this is a nod to the robert
pattinson movie called good time matt
reeves cast rob after watching it so
this is a really nice detail however i
haven't seen anyone point out yet that
the robber himself actually wears
similar clothes to what pattinson had on
the film including a grey hoodie with an
orangey red jacket over the top of it
after batman beats up the black and
white gang he then travels to the
mayor's office which heavily mirrors the
shot and silence of the lambs when the
police all looked at chloe stalling
later on when batman confronts thriller
and arkham we also get similar framing
to when clarice met hannibal lecter and
as batman says
it's all connected he says says it like
that it's all connected now reeves has
been very clear about his influences
when producing this film this includes
zodiac 7 and halloween a huge shout out
to ryan airy for pointing out that the
riddler's introduction somewhat mirrors
michael myers in that film as we see
things through his point of view as he
carries out his first murder bearing the
halloween influence in mind i went back
and re-watched the movie and we also get
a scene where michael sits in the back
of someone's car before murdering them
which massively plays on when the
riddler does it to the da shout out to
greg from real rejects for also pointing
out that the opening is very similar to
the 70s movie the conversation which
centers around the voya there's several
via shots in the movie including the one
in which we see bruce walking through
the crowd this is all shot from behind
as is the moment where he removes his
motorbike helmet this bit is mirrored
when we see his back scars and he walks
along which is then coupled by us
following gordon from behind it's a
really cool aesthetic and in some ways
it makes us feel like we're following
the characters too now everything is a
big play by the riddler to get falcone
aka the mob boss that runs the city
every single tv show game and film
before this it's pronounced it falcone
however i think they choose falcom for
this movie for a specific reason this is
so that it's closer to falcon and the
riddler describes the characters a rat
with wings which though typically a bat
could also be a nod to that bird riddler
wants batman to bring falcone out of the
club so he can snipe him from his window
and it is possible that in his final few
moments he recognizes him as bruce
earlier in the movie he talks about a
moment that was shown in the long
halloween in which he was taken to wayne
manor after being shot falcone said that
as he was being operated on that bruce
looked down on him and this moment is
very much mirrored here he was initially
supposed to die at this point but he was
saved by thomas which in some ways is
mirrored in bruce who fails to save his
life in this moment it's a brilliant way
to mirror father and son and in this
light we can see the scar and falcon's
face a hell of a lot better this was
given to him by selena which is a
reference to batmania 1 in which she
also did the same thing to him he also
mentioned zorro at one point and if
you're familiar with the comics zara was
the film that bruce want to see as a kid
that led to his parents getting murdered
so he probably doesn't like that much
probably give it one percent on rotten
tomatoes if it was up to him he's been
bloody review bombing it are we learning
the film that he possibly had the wanes
killed after thomas asked him to silence
a journalist and on screen the words
hush appear the journalist surname is
also elliot which is likely a reference
to thomas elliot aka hush now dc
recently released an animated movie
based on the graphic novel but rather
than keeping elliot as part of it they
revealed at the end that it was the
riddler behind everything now you can
interpret that the riddler is actually
the son of the journalist and nurse
falcone having him killed also mirrors
the fact that falcone potentially killed
the waynes this would make batman and
the riddler a hell of a lot more similar
and it's such a cool detail that i
really appreciate in the movie now both
the journalists and riddler are called
edward and no it's never confirmed i do
feel like the whole hush connection and
riddler thing might be there if you look
hard enough which i am because i don't
really have a life cheers now in the
photo we see him as a child he's also in
a choir which makes sense as to why the
song ave maria pops up so many times in
the movie you also see a cease and
desist letter sent to the journalist and
along the top of it you can catch the
names miller and mua which are both a
reference to frank miller and alemur
these guys made some seminal batman
graphic novels including batman year one
the dark knight returns and also the
killing joke so it's really nice that
they got some appreciation in this movie
at one point now not long after the
police find the riddler in a cafe and
they slam his head against the counter
which cracks his glasses this crack can
actually be seen in all the appearances
he makes from this point out and i love
this attention to detail from the
costume department you can also catch
that his costume has cellophane wrapped
behind his mask so that he doesn't leave
any dna behind for forensics to find
apparently this detail is also in the
funko pops but i don't really know as i
don't know what funko pops are now his
gang ended up attacking bella real and
earlier in the movie there's actually a
line that foreshadows this entire plan
when batman attempts to take the colour
off gil coulson we can see the riddler
is live streaming the entire thing
amongst the comments is one that says
hope it's a dud and we gotta do it all
again tuesday which sets up the attack
that comes at the end of the movie gil
coulson's license plate is also s397wd
which could be a reference to batman's
first appearance in detective comics 27
which was released in 1939. many of the
offices in the movie are also from the
39th precinct and like i've been telling
you for years and like batman said it's
all connected now we're wrapping up the
video because i've got to leave the cave
and go watch the movie for a fifth time
but i'm just going to leave you with
some more little bits of trivia did you
know zoe kravitz also voiced catwoman in
the lego batman movie you didn't well
shut up and listen what's up when the
penguin when he gets tied up yeah the
penguin you know the guy he waddles off
like a bit of a penguin doesn't he
that's a nice little touch and people
say this movie doesn't have jokes that's
hilarious so yeah we've got those insane
details we've got those inane details
and i hope that you enjoyed the video
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the opening which will be
linked on screen right now we talk about
why the aesthetic of it works so well
and why it's our favorite batman scene
ever so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more by the way
thanks for sticking through the video
i've been poor i'll see you in the next
one take care peace